Це нова реальність?
У Німеччині, Великобританії та США відбуваються акції протесту
проти карантинних заходів і тих,
хто поширює різноманітні теорії змови, чути все голосніше.
Вони вважають, що таємні організації
стоять за спалахом коронавірусу.
Уряд скористався вірусом.
Це просто засіб досягнення мети,
і вони домагаються іншого порядку денного.
Ми не можемо й далі друкувати гроші, бо все закінчиться,
як у 1930-ті в Німеччині.
Як поводитися з такими заплутаними твердженнями?
Піа Ламберті написала книгу, в якій проаналізувала,
що думають прихильники теорій змови.
За її словами, у таких людей спрацьовує інстинкт,
щоб відчувати себе у безпеці і мати ситуацію під контролем.
У ситуації, коли ми мало що можемо контролювати,
теоретики змов надають зрозумілу структуру і сенс тому, що відбувається.
Вірус невидимий. Це невидима загроза.
Тож ви не можете протестувати проти вірусу, це не допоможе.
Але якщо це подати так,
що за цим хтось стоїть,
то вже можна діяти.
Під цим сюжетом на сторінці DW у Фейсбук чимало коментарів.
Відео показує роботу українських лікарів у Чернівцях,
яким бракує захисного спорядження та устаткування.
Утім, багато коментаторів сумніваються в справжньості сказаного
й показаного у відео, запевняючи,
що "ніякого коронавірусу не існує".
Це те саме, що прирівняти, що на сході немає війни,
тому що ти її не бачиш.
Правильно? Тому нема.
Але хтось тобі доказує, що вона є.
І  ти не віриш.
Так само можна говорити про цей вірус,
тому що той,хто всередині, він бачить,
тому що пару хвилин ти так маєш пересидіти.
Це таке...  А коли ховати?
Коли помирають?
Теорії змови існують віддавна.
Серед них - і вбивство президента США Джона Кеннеді спецслужбами.
І те, що смерть принцеси Діани тривалий час планувалась.
Або що сліди від літаків - це насправді
розпилювання токсичних хімікатів.
Чи те, що теракти 11 вересня здійснив уряд США.
А прихильники конспірологічної теорії "QAnon",
яка поширюється у соцмережах,
вважають, що багато знаменитостей
беруть участь у педофільській секті.
Я проти того, щоб називати їх божевільними або дурними людьми.
Це неправда. Але я думаю,
що варто бути обережними,
щоб не занурюватись у дискусії про це.
Ми повинні зрозуміти їхні страхи.
Всі вони просто стурбовані громадяни
і водночас їм нав'язують такі образи ворога.
Нині Білл Гейтс - головна мішень для ненависті.
Теоретики змов стверджують, що засновник Microsoft допоміг розробити коронавірус,
і він навіть хоче імплантувати чіпи в людей, щоб контролювати їхнє здоров'я.
Відео німецького теоретика змов Кена Єбсена проти Білла Гейтса
зібрало понад три мільйони переглядів на YouTube.
Чи треба носити маску чи ні,
чи перебуває ця країна на карантині чи ні,
це все зараз визначають Білл та Мелінда Гейтс.
Як нам поводитися з людьми, які відмовляються слухати?
Якщо вони відкидають будь-яку критику і коли все стає настільки розмитим?
Я думаю, що за останні кілька тижнів
наше усвіомлення зросло: о, у нас проблема.
Чи побільшає прихильників теорій змови,
і чи стануть вони голоснішими у найближчі тижні?
Зрозуміло одне: теорії змови будуть завжди, особливо у кризові часи.